[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bon soir c'est dire
bonsoir patrice amené ravi de vous
retrouver en direct pour ce set puis de
nouvelles formules l'appelle sa dream
team parce que steam comme talk info
magazine avec un sommet extrêmement
riche donc je ne peux pas vous expliquer
tout ce qui nous attend dans cette
émission tabac on commence tout de suite
par le sommaire le salon eurosatory se
déroulant jusqu'au 17 juin au parc des
expositions de villepinte il est
consacré à la défense et à la sécurité
terrestre et aéro terrestre en
ile-de-france le secteur de la défense
représente plus de 45 1000 salariés le
département des yvelines est le premier
d'île de france en terme de salariés
avec 25% des effectifs notre journaliste
nicolas landry s'est rendu sur place au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les plus
grandes stars de youtube et de twitch
s'affronteront dans une compétition
virtuelle ou de cyclisme samedi 18 juin
présenté par domingo il a annoncé un
format en duo parmi les têtes d'affiché
mcfly et carlito ceratins ou encore en
côte à gas et enfin une grande première
dans l'histoire du rugby club de
versailles l'équipe senior accède à la
fédérale 2 on en parlera au cours de
l'émission avec des membres du club et
ben merci beaucoup c'est lire et on va
passer avec vous justin brasier bas d
info qu'il fallait retenir dans
l'actualité du jour
alors dans l'actualité dans les yvelines
semaine après les intempéries l'état de
catastrophe naturelle a été décrété pour
neuf villes yvelinoise un arrêté publié
au journal officiel du 12 juin il
concerne débile comme rambouillet son
chant ou encore dampierre en yvelines
pour rappel les 4 et 5 juin orages et
grêle avait un pacte et les récoltes de
plusieurs exploitations dans le sud du
département et après les épreuves
écrites de spécialité en mai dernier les
épreuves écrites d'enseignements
généraux du baccalauréat ont débuté le
14 juin les résultats seront
consultables en ligne mardi 5 juillet
selon les chiffres de l'académie de
versailles près 2 68 mille candidats ont
passé le bac en 2021 dans l'académie
pour un taux de réussite de 93,1 % en
moyenne côté santé ce mardi 14 juin
signé la journée mondiale des donneurs
de sang objectif de cette journée
sensibiliser et rendre hommage à tous
les donneurs l'occasion de faire le
point sur les réserves actuelles des
stocks en baisse l'établissement
français du sang appelle à la
mobilisation un manque de vingt mille
poches de sang pour répondre aux besoins
des malades est constatée en sport la
finale de la coupe des yvelines se
jouera ce dimanche 19 juin le voisin
football club affrontera l'équipe de
réserve de trappes est la rencontre est
prévue au stade de la couldre à montigny
le bretonneux est le vainqueur
remportera donc la compétition coup
d'envoi du match à 16h15 et puis
attention à la chaleur la france observe
un épisode caniculaire précoce si pour
l'heure les yvelines ne figure pas parmi
les départements en vigilance
un pic de chaleur pourrait être atteint
ce week-end dans le département selon
des prévisions à météo france entre 36
et 39 degrés attendus donc dans les
yvelines ce samedi après-midi n'oubliez
pas de vous hydrater merci justin est
justement nous nous sommes partis à la
rencontre des yvelinois pour leur
demander s'ils souffraient de la chaleur
et quels gestes à adopter regarder on
ferme les volets
on reste chez soi au maximum à l'ombre
on boit beaucoup je joue avec les volets
et les fenêtres et j'ai tenu à ne pas
changer mes volets qui sont en bois de
22 mm d'épaisseur c'est en béton pour
les personnes âgées mais sinon à la
pastèque on al 2011
on a tout ce qu'il faut pour la canicule
n'y a pas de souci ça change un peu
commencé un peu plus tôt et sur ton mais
plus la lac leamy tout ça faut tenir la
température ambiante entre 0 et 5 degrés
moi j'apprécie énormément le soleil je
suis né au soleil donc ça me plaît très
bien pour savoir comme ça on bronze un
peu ça fait du bien mais on s'est
beaucoup plaint du froid maintenant il
fait beau alors on profite et justement
on va parler de cette vague de chaleur
ou de cette plume de chaleur de dir écho
bon il faut dire avec vous alain bazot
vous êtes chercheur émérite au
laboratoire des sciences du climat et de
l'environnement vous êtes climatologues
donc alors peut-être que la première
question d y ait d'abord sait d'où elle
vient cette vague de chaleur pas dehors
explique comment il explique c'est de
l'air très chaud qui vient en gros
d'afrique du nord et il est remonté
parce que au large de l'espagne et il ya
un anticyclone qui tourne dans le sens
inverse des aiguilles d'une montre et
humour et envoie tout cet air chaud via
l'espagne et qui atteint la france et
donc ça fait une sorte de plume de prime
1 oui ça dépend si c'est stationnaire ou
pas là ça doit quelques jours mais donc
il ya beaucoup d'air très chaud qui
remonte à cause de la configuration
météorologique
d'une manière générale c'est des choses
qui peuvent arriver parce que
perturbations anticyclone ça bouge tout
le temps mais là c'est quand même très
marqué et ce genre d'événement est
favorisée et puis aussi les plus forts à
cause du réchauffement climatique alors
var est vrai dire le changement
climatique parce que c'est le seul fondé
des choses
mais on va atteindre 35 37 degrés à
donner dans les jours qui viennent
probablement
quand est ce qu'on parle de canicule
c'est ses sacs à légumes alors la
canicule on peut discuter la définition
en principe c'est quand il fait disons
pour paris plus de 20° trois nuits de
suite c'est ça c'est rien c'est ça la
des températures dépend pas d'eux ne
descend pas pardon en dessous de 20
degrés pendant plusieurs jours de suite
pendant la nuit et j'ai regardé un petit
peu apparemment la définition change un
petit peu les villes du sud on considère
que c'est peut-être 22 ou 23 voilà mais
enfin c'est ça c'est quand la
température nocturnes ne descendent pas
que c'est à dire que en a pas de
fraîcheur on avait des rires des choses
assez incroyable succès vers montpellier
ou alors tout d'un coup à deux heures du
matin la température monte extrêmement 1
puis redescend oui parce que montpellier
temps et plein dans laxe là aujourd'hui
j'ai regardé un peu les températures il
a quand même fait 37 toulouse 34 à lyon
28 à paris demain 41 et toulouse 1 ça
commence très très chaud
lyon 35 paris 34 samedi sur les trois
villes 38 ans et les fortes températures
ce sont des records pour la mesure parce
que derrière je ne sais pas je j'avoue
que je ne sais pas c'est en tout cas des
températures très forte et si c'est pas
les records sans n'est pas loin ce qui
est vrai c'est que c'est des phénomènes
auxquels on commence à s'habituer enfin
il ya déjà eu d'autres et est
probablement enfin ça c'est à vous de le
dire avec lui il y en aura de plus en
plus oui oui donc il y en a si j'ose
dire toujours eu parce que c'est lié à
la configuration météo mais il y en aura
de plus en plus d'abord parce que la
saison chaude la saison d'été disons
s'agrandit harry fait chaud plus tôt
dans la saison et le l'automne
donc ce genre de vague de chaleur à plus
de temps pour arriver 1 donc ça c'est
une trés bien raison la vague de chaleur
et est amplifié parce que finalement à
cause du réchauffement l'air est aussi
plus chaud et c de température ou si
vous passez de 34° à 36 degrés c'est ce
soir 500 voilà ça sent ça joue et le
troisième point ça risque d'être plus
fréquents parce que globalement le
système climatique disons tropicale
celui de l'afrique du nord avec le
réchauffement a tendance à s'étendre
donc du coup les masses d'air ont encore
à quelque sorte - de chemin à faire pour
venir vers vers le sud de la france donc
il faut s'attendre à d'autres vagues et
avec des températures qui sont encore
plus c'est hors de toute façon il ya le
réchauffement la tendance au
réchauffement donc les records que soi
même le record absolu 46 degrés il sera
abattu mardi des ducks étaient quand
c'était il ya deux ans je crois à peu
près il ya eu une canicule avec 46
degrés je sais plus le nom de vinci
d'affronter un temps que c'est c'est le
record est si dense la france lors de
l'es7 permettre sa
v2 sont sales je veux dire c'est
quasiment le bon sens c'est très
difficile de supporter surtout les
personnes fragiles des personnes qui
vivent dans des logements qui sont mal
isolés mal clim mal climatisé et dévoile
à tout ça donc personne qui peut vivre à
l'extérieur
donc oui bien sûr l'impact jeu il ya eu
la canicule de 2003 quand même donc
l'impact sur la santé il peut être
très grave donc bon maintenant il ya
plus de prévention explique davantage je
crois vraiment les messages passent mais
le problème reste quand même c'est quand
même des événements importants une
division
cette séance c'est un peu de la nasse
dire concertée actuelle bon c'est un
épisode de du réchauffement climatique
alors aujourd'hui c'est vrai que plus
personne ne remet en cause la réalité du
réchauffement climatique mais parfois on
se demande est-ce qu'on peut rien ce qui
n'est pas encore trop tard il n'est
jamais trop tard de toute façon c'est un
peu comme si on arrive trop vite sur un
virage en épingle à cheveux
même si on freine tard il n'est jamais
trop tard pour freiner ce qui est grave
c'est pas freddy nock donc on voit là
tout n'est pas perdu non qu'un rien
perdu mais en fait c'est une question de
modération on s'adaptera et on
supportera portera mieux un
réchauffement d'amplitude relativement
limité disons
un degré ou de gré ou même peut-être 2°
demi par approprient industriel quand
réchauffement qui peut atteindre 4 à 5
degrés est ses températures globales sur
toute la surface de la planète aussi en
comprenait qu'il réchauffe plus tôt
c'est à dire bien il ya des phénomènes
aussi aux nouveaux par exemple on a
entendu à des feux de forêt maintenant
en ile de france oui parce que quand il
fait chaud sacré plus d'évaporation
donc c'est plus sec donc c'est plus
propice aux feux et c'est vrai vraiment
dans le sud de la france mais ça peut
aussi arriver en ile de france parce que
ben voilà une fois que c'est bien c'est
qu'il suffit d'un geste ou à narva ça
augmente les chances que qui a un
incendie qui démarre parce que c'est
plus sec parce qu'il ya eu plus
d'évaporation parce qu'il fait plus
chaud non juste l'occasion peut-être
pour couples ubs que le chercheur que
vous êtes vous êtes optimiste sur le
combat qu'on a à me défense à ce
réchauffement est quand même là je la
nécropole il ya des choses il ya des
efforts de fait bon ben la transition
énergétique
il faut la faire le passage vers les
voitures électriques c'est quand même
une bonne chose si vous faites que des
petits trajets en ville ou en autour de
la ville en région et que vous pouvez
faire relativement facilement brancher
votre voiture vraiment je recommande
donc l'isolation des bâtiments c'est
quand même des programmes vraiment
important pour économiser l'énergie donc
émettre moins de gaz à effet de serre
parce que souvent le chauffage c'est le
gaz etc donc oui il ya des chose de
faite mais pas assez sympa assez vite
par rapport c'est un peu une course à
l'échalote et c'est ce qu'on voit là
mais c'est évident qu'il faut continuer
et amplifier l'effort il est possible
que ce genre de vague de chaleur fait
une prise de conscience qui peut
attendre
we serve à quelque chose oui ça sert à
quelque chose mais souvent
les gens sont un peu fataliste et mais
bon
on peut voir comme ça quand même merci
il reste avec nous oui avec nous parce
qu'on va parler aussi d'environnement on
va s'intéresser maintenant un projet
d'un collégien et depuis deux ans et des
élèves du collège pierre de coubertin à
chevreuse travail sur l'influencé de
l'activité humaine sur l'environnement
mathilde vous faire en sorte alors vous
allez nous expliquer en quoi consiste ce
projet 1 c'est ça exactement ces liens
sont ses projets erasmus plus il a
débuté dans le collège pierre de
coubertin à chevreuse il y a deux ans
maintenant c'est un projet qui s'étend à
l'échelle européenne avec en tout cinq
partenaires la roumanie le portugal la
croatie la guadeloupe et la france sur
un thème commun l'impact de l'humain sur
le climat c'est un thème très actuel que
nous avons à coeur d'aborder et de on se
doit aussi l éducation nationale
d'éduquer au développement durable de
sensibiliser nos élèves et et les amener
aussi à prendre des initiatives à
travers
le groupe d co délégué mais aussi à
travers des projets de classe des
projets le projet d'établissement alors
chacun des pays a étudié un thème
différent est préoccupant pour son
territoire par exemple la métropole
française à travailler sur la transition
écologique notamment sur le fait de
consommer et cultivé responsable le
portugal et la croatie eux ont travaillé
sur le thème de l'eau puis les élèves et
les enseignants sont partis rencontrer
les partenaires regarde un bilan de ses
deux années au niveau des élèves
c'était très riche en rencontres une
prise de conscience ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose auquel je n'impose pas se
passer pas du tout le travail par projet
ça c'est fantastique aussi pour certains
parce que voilà ça les motive ça leur
donne envie nous sommes aussi allés à la
rencontre de l'or et de yann dans le
cadre de ce projet ils sont partis en
roumanie et en croatie écoutez moi j'ai
appris que déjà la montée des eaux
n'était pas seulement dû aux humains
mais aussi que la planète à des phases
de réchauffement et elle a des périodes
glaciaires et des périodes où elle
serait chaud avec une personne du pnr in
est venu il nous a expliqué tout ce qui
avec toutes les plantes tous les
bienfaits qu'elles font et où du coup il
y en a qui ont été plantés du coup au
potager et il nous a expliqué aussi des
techniques dont la ola kind un groupe
inter convient m dans la terre et comblé
remplir d'eau qui va arroser plus en
profondeur la terre et qui fait des
économies d'eau et le jour où nous les
avons rencontrés il faisait une fresque
du climat alors qu'est ce que c'est une
fresque du climat en fait c'est un
immense jeu de cartes ils ont créé un
immense jeu de cartes avec des liens de
cause à conséquence
je travaillais plus tôt sur
les canicules la sécheresse etc
et donc on vole y donc par exemple on a
le réchauffement de la terre donc le
réchauffement de la terre il va
engranger des canicules qui des
sécheresses et au final du manque de
nourriture ou des familles et puis ces
famines ça va entraîner des réfugiés
climatiques et donc des confirmés
ensuite par la suite donc c'est vraiment
une chose ça en dange les conséquences
des centaines de conséquences et donc
c'est très enrichissant faire la phrase
ça nous apprend plein de choses voilà
donc les deux millions presque seront
ensuite différents affichée dans le hall
du collège est donc ce projet erasmus
plus est amenée à se renouveler dans ce
collège à l'avenir merci beaucoup at il
un bon quand même de du petit bateau
l'homme c'est bien ça oui tout ça c'est
des très bonne initiative c'est
évidemment les jeunes qu'il faut cibler
et ils sont très intéressés très
concernés en général pas plus tard
qu'hier on a eu des visites de deux
lycéens de seconde et bat vraiment ça
des choses mais pose des questions et
sont concernés c'est évident que c'est
la cible il faut bon faut pas non plus
les assommer en quelque sorte mais je
trouve que tout ça c'est très bien le
jeu du climat et d'être très bien voilà
donc en plus l'aspect international bon
ben c'est bien mais c'est bien qu'ils
aillent romain dit qu'ils aillent dans
les pays n'ayant pas meilleure à
l'époque actuelle où un bon oui on est
on est tous dans le même bateau au moins
ça montre que vraiment c'est très
positif et c'est très utile parce que
ils sont aux premières loges en quelque
sorte et
invités ils ont conscience
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup à
l'inversé beaucoup de mathilde on va
parler de sécurité de défausse avec vous
nicolas maintenant effectivement je suis
me suis rendu à eurosatory en fait c'est
le salon international de la sécurité de
la défense et alors j'ai vu des
militaires j'ai vu des industriels de la
défense j'ai vu des start up des pme
direction donc le parc des expositions
de villepinte et ce qui est marquant eh
bien ça ce côté international en fait il
ya des stands aux couleurs de différents
pays j'ai vu les pays bas j'ai vu la
chine j'ai vu même l'ukraine qui est
mise à l'honneur au sein du salon et
et tout ça
alors eurosatory je vous expliquerai
pour après et le plus impressionnant
c'est le pavillon américain regardez ces
images y avait des entreprises
américaines venues présenter leurs
innovations l'armée américaine a exposé
ces masses son matériel vous voyez ce
char voyez cet hélicoptère américain et
il y avait même une tribune destinée au
speaker c'est à dire qu'elle ait des
conférences organisées par les
américains au sein de ce salon et vous
avez pu peut-être vous approcher des
chars
exactement je suis rendu notamment sur
le stand de nexter nexter c'est le
groupe qui est implantée à versailles
qui fabrique des blindés ou des canons
vous voyez c'est blindé ce char leclerc
xl'r c'est le dernier charles leclerc
vous voyez aussi ses canons ces
différents blindés je me suis aussi
après rendu sur le site le stand du
ministère des armées et regardez j'ai pu
monter dans cet hélicoptère
l'hélicoptère des forces spéciales de
nh90 je suis allé jusqu au cockpit vos
loyers à l'image et j'ai même pu voir
ses cordages en fait utilisé par les
soldats militaire qui descendent on
appelle ça la hero corp d'ailleurs que
les militaires peuvent descendre au sol
à partir de ces longues cordes et passer
une belle journée mais j'ai passé une
très bonne journée alors patrice
justement regarder ce blindé je sais pas
si vous en souvenez investi on est
montés dessus
j'ai plus pour avoir contesté mobilité
de oui oui c'était des missions
spéciales émission spéciale du 7-8 échos
et on nous sommes avec patrice carmouze
bonjour nicolas est bon on est bien
installé dans on est très bien installés
alors c'est le gris foncé ça un bon fond
absolument voilà c'est doux souvenirs
les matériels assez incroyable
exactement c'était à la stat c'est le
service technique de l'armée terre et
c'était plus précisément au sein de la
cellule innovation le battle l'aptr qui
est installé donc la personne plateau de
satory c'était une émission pour parler
justement des innovations de la défense
et alors il faut savoir que le
département des yvelines est quand même
rigueur le présent le secteur de la
défense est bien représenté dans le
département des yvelines ces onze mille
plus de 11000 emplois dans le
département ça représente 25 % des
effectifs du secteur d'activité en ile
de france c'est le premier département
en ile-de-france dans le cadre de ces
secteurs dans le secteur de la défense
c'est le troisième département au niveau
de la france sont donc les yvelines très
engagée dans le secteur de la défense et
dans les yvelines ya plusieurs grands
groupes qu'on connaît donc je vous ai
parlé de nexter mais il ya aussi airbus
défense n space à elancourt il ya ariane
space à aux mureaux nous avons aussi
thales aa long cours et il ya aussi
safran à magny les hameaux et puis je
vous propose d'ailleurs de découvrir
deux innovations développées par deux
entreprises yvelinoise elles ont été
présentés cette semaine au salon
eurosatory et la spécificité c'est
qu'elles sont adaptées au contexte
actuel de la guerre en ukraine regarder
c'est le dernier véhicule blindé
innovante du groupe arcus le cheikh pas
à 2m a été conçu au sein du bureau
d'études implanté sur le plateau de
satory à versailles un co-développement
avec deux autres entreprises thales et
le groupe espagnol ntg s on arrive un
véhicule qui est rapide mobile bien
protégé avec un système qui se déploie
automatiquement à l'arrière du véhicule
donc sans intervention humaine le
pointage ce fait honneur automatique
également par le chef de bord à
l'intérieur l'idée de base du véhicule
c'est d'arriver rapidement sur une
position proche de l'ennemi on espère
porter de 8 à 13 km un peu plus il y en
a pas des munitions guidées laser de
tirer sur l'adversaire est en fait
d'être parti avant même que l'adversaire
commence à utiliser des moyens de
contrôle batterie c'est à dire de
détection en vue du départ du tir leader
européen des véhicules blindés arcus
emploie 600 personnes dans le
département des yvelines du côté de
saint germain les l'entreprise x blue
est spécialisée dans les technologies de
pointe au début engagés dans le civil
elle a orienté son activité dans la
défense navale puis terrestre x blue
développe notamment un gyroscope à fibre
optique destinée aux blindés s'agissant
par exemple de la défense on va avoir
des applications qui sont dehors de la
navigation et du pointage donc la
navigation cela signifie concrètement
qu'on va pouvoir obtenir la position en
temps réel d'un véhicule sans avoir
recours à des signaux extérieurs tels
que le gps ou galileo pour l'europe
c'est tout l'avantagé d'avoir une
navigation inertielle c'est qu'on va
pouvoir se priver totalement des signes
à l'extérieur donc pour les forces ça
présente un avantage majeur étant donné
que
on le voit avec le contexte actuel les
menaces de brouillage et de leur âge de
ces signaux extérieurs sont présents et
pour avoir des conséquences dramatiques
pour l'opération dans le sang sont un
véhicule pourrait se retrouver perdu en
prime le champ de bataille dans les
yvelines le secteur de la défense
emploie plus de 11 mille personnes c'est
le premier département d'ile-de-france
dans cette activité en termes d'emploi
merci beaucoup dit que la dri on va
ouvrir maintenant notre pass culturel de
sessa avec donc deux invités pour deux
sujets différents alors on va vous
dévoiler la saison culturelle 2022 2023
de montigny le bretonneux
il y a eu des nouvelles des nouveautés a
apparemment du côté des formules
d'abonnement et en parlera aussi d'un
événement culturel qui a lieu au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
les plus grandes stars du stream seront
présentes mais avant cela on va
accueillir donc je vais kasha bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le maire adjoint à la
culture de montigny le bretonneux
alors la saison culturelle le prochaine
est déjà acté alors est ce que en avant
première vous pouvez nous donner un peu
les temps forts de cette saison bien que
des temps forts où
il ya les actes et allait même dans les
boîtes aux lettres donc lésigny montain
eu l'occasion de la découvrir des temps
forts bah disons l'ouverture de saison
déjà puisqu'on aura le plaisir
d'accueillir
une pièce de théâtre qui a été écrite et
mise en scène par samuel benchetrit avec
samuel benchetrit et vanessa paradis
donc bon d'infos sur ces gros temps fort
je ne vais pas vous faire le descriptif
de toutes les spectacles qui il est les
moments de nostalgie aussi enfin un peu
de tout du théâtre de la musique voilà
des variétés la musique danse comme on
essaie de le faire systématiquement
vincent
clerc qui vient
d'annoncer une nouvelle très belle
progression d'à côté merci
c'est bien c'est compliqué ou pas de
programmer un théâtre comme alors ses
complices album aussi si on se base sur
les deux années qui viennent de
s'écouler on peut dire ça a été
extrêmement précaires extrêmement
compliqué l'année dernière enfin quand
je dis l'année dernière l'année qui
s'achève là on était essentiellement sur
une programmation qui était faite de
report de l'année précédente puisque
bien évidemment les les productions et
les pièces de théâtre et concerts n'ont
pas pu se tenir comme ça devait l'être
là cette année de toute façon on sent
une envie oui de redire globale et le
redémarrage
mais avec des choses qui font sens
effectivement parfois compliqué en terme
de programmation notamment en termes de
concert puisque on sent qu'il ya
beaucoup d'artistes qui souhaite
repartir mais qui souhaite repartir sur
des grandes scènes
et la capacité d'accueillir sait combien
on est sur deux salles la salle jacques
brel 330 places la ferme du manège
jusqu'à 750 places assises on a 500
debout donc non on a la capacité pour
aller et pour cette nouvelle saison par
mois il ya donc du changement au niveau
abonnement il ya trois ans nous formules
d'abonnement c'est ça et de l'adhésion
est ce que vous pouvez on peut nous
expliquer bien sûr bon d'abord c'est une
un engagement que nous avions pris en
début de mandat et que et que nous
souhaitons tenir donc c'est d'une façon
avant tout de remercier les gens qui
nous sont fidèles depuis tant d'années
mais aussi d'aller chercher un public
qu'on n'a pas aujourd'hui donc on a
effectivement une proposition autour de
trois formules d'abonnement beaucoup
passionnément à la folie donc les
abonnés
moulé sur des abonnements donc pour pour
beaucoup de 3,5 spectacle
passionnément de 6 à 8 et à la folie 9
et au delà et avec pour le premier la
possibilité de bénéficier de 20 % de
réduction sur l'ensemble des achats 30 %
sur le deuxième et 40 % sur le troisième
on peut toujours éventuellement de faire
aller voir un spectacle au choix
conserve jusqu'à présent c'est-à-dire la
vérification c'est bien le spectacle
voilà et de formule d'adhésion alors
deux formules d'adhésion une qui est qui
s'adresse aux 18 25 ans parce que les 18
25 ans on a aussi envie qu'ils viennent
nous rendre visite et donc les 18 25 ans
l'adhésion est simple il suffit
d'acheter un coupon d'adhésion à 10
euros de choisir trois spectacles au
minimum et chaque spectacle leur coûtera
systématiquement 10 euros quel que soit
le type
parce que c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup de
l'abonnement on le voit dans les villes
voisines qui cible un petit peu les
catégories de spectacles etc enfin qui
oriente ce choix nous c'est vraiment
c'est tout scène un spectacle tout
concert et deuxième formule d'adhésion
qui elle s'adresse aux familles de
quatre ou plus pourquoi parce que les
cancers ont fini avec
sa famille à commenailles brossé cher
là c'est une possibilité pour eux ou
pareil on est sur un coupon d'adhésion à
l'année de 10 euros pour l'ensemble de
la famille et après ça tout ça permettra
pour chaque spectacle de bénéficier
d'une réduction de 30%
et puis on a un mois j'ai le savez le
parfum alors par fin de saison c'est
le programme c'est un travail qu'on fait
en partenariat avec notre conservatoire
des arts puisque ce sont des élèves du
conservatoire des arts de montigny qui
sont chargés d'illustration de la compo
derniers temps des fêtes bravo
merci vous
vous faites du vélo moi oui
enfin on peut parler d'un événement qui
va se passer samedi avec nous
vous êtes responsable marketing et
communication de vélo police c'est bien
ça et c'est un événement qui a été créé
par un youtube heures qui s'appelle
domingo c'est la quatrième édition je
crois que ça s'appelle l'échappée à
l'aube raconte-nous quoi
félicitations donc effectivement on est
on est ravis d'accueillir cette
quatrième édition de l'échappée au brome
nationale donc assez exceptionnel
puisque c'est une édition qui rassemble
les meilleurs streamer les plus célèbres
ou youtube heures de la place actuelle
donc très synthétique mans c'est une
compétition virtuelle de cyclisme donc
les streamer vont s'affronter sur un
parcours ville virtuelle de 30 km
ils font semblant de pédaler alors
justement on est vraiment je valais
entre le esport ce qu'on appelle le 10
sport n'est finalement le gaming ce
qu'on est sûr on est sur un vélo donc ce
qu'on appelle nous la plateforme juif tu
es on réellement donc on est
vraiment entre 2 à mi chemin entre le
sport le ea sports et le gagner c'est
aussi la dden du vélodrome c'est
d'attirer tous types de spectacles
culturels spectacles vivants spectacle
sportif et de créer des connexions des
passerelles entre ces différents univers
c'est ce qu'on tente à travers cette
première cette première grande échéance
est donc resté au vélodrome on voit quoi
un gros alors on voit différentes choses
donc on va évidemment assister au
baptême de cyclisme sur piste de ces
streamer qui vont pour la première et à
fouler le parquet de la piste et puis
dans un second temps le show le show qui
va être retransmis en live sur le sur un
bateau twitch donc suivi par un temps
des pics à 500 1000 followers donc c'est
c'est pas rien loïc sécher
une plateforme de streaming comme à une
sorte de réseau social des temps
modernes et domingo
et
effectivement on aura un live à travers
ce show qui sera diffusé auprès de
auprès des jeunes de génération y et z
comme un
ballet
notoriété le territoire saint quentin en
yvelines aussi c'est ça reste assez
connus terrain de sport terre
d'innovation donc
rejoint l'adn du territoire et puis
aujourd'hui le vélodrome on a aussi
l'ambition de diversifier ses activités
donc sport spectacle vivant comme tu
l'as dit plus aujourd'hui gaming semble
un gaming et ea sports on continue sur
cette voie au niveau des têtes d'affiché
ce que vous pouvez nous dire il ya un mc
fly carlito par exemple est-ce que vous
pouvez nous c'est bien ça car il touche
un nageur carlitos et une prépa la
compétition samedi c'est pour ça
commence avec sur scène
donc aller les meilleurs youtuber
ventoux enfin tout le monde les connaît
maintenant et puis c'est encore une fois
je le souligne c'est exceptionnel de les
avoir au vélodrome national samedi donc
on attend beaucoup de choses de ceux de
ce show et c'est une première on va dire
que la première version événementiel de
ce concept de l'échappée overall
nationale encore une fois donc on était
bien en effet en un bord et s'est ab
s'arrogeant la programmation de prestige
de josé donc bref vraiment c'est vrai
contrat qu'on tende là ça fait 2 2 voies
la mode il faut attendre un peu la
saison prochaine à
1,5 en septembre la programmation
certain temps mais par contre la vente
de la biette et la vente sera donné
à 18h alors c'est simple samedi tous au
vélodrome et lundi tous à la veillée
touche devant l'air
la chose
est maintenant mathilde de nouveaux
rouges ont toujours été avec nous
est-ce que vous pouvez peut-être me
résumer les 5 infos du jour alors oui ce
qu'il faut retenir de l'actualité dans
les yvelines célia c'est une semaine
après les intempéries
l'état de catastrophe naturelle a été
décrété pour neuf villes yvelinoise un
arrêté publié au journal officiel du 12
juin il concerne des villes comme
rambouillet son chant ou encore
dampierre en yvelines pour rappel les 4
et 5 juin orages et grêle avait un pacte
et les récoltes de plusieurs
exploitations dans le sud du département
après les épreuves écrites de spécialité
1 mai dernier les épreuves écrites
d'enseignements généraux du baccalauréat
ont débuté le 14 juin les résultats
seront consultables en ligne mardi 5
juillet selon les chiffres de l'académie
de versailles près de 68 mille candidats
ont passé le bac en 2021 dans l'académie
pour un taux de réussite de 93,1 % en
moyenne côté santé ce mardi 14 juin
signé la journée mondiale des donneurs
de sang objectif de cette journée
sensibiliser et rendre hommage à tous
les donneurs l'occasion de faire le
point sur les réserves actuelles des
stocks en baisse l'établissement
français du sang appelle à la
mobilisation
un manque 25 20 20 mille pardons poches
de sang pour répondre aux besoins des
malades est constatée en sport la finale
de la coupe des yvelines se jouera ce
dimanche 19 juin le voisin football club
affrontera l'équipe réserve de trappes
la rencontre est prévue au stade de la
couldre à montigny le bretonneux le
vainqueur remportera la compétition coup
d'envoi du match à 16h15 et puis
attention à la chaleur la france observe
un épisode caniculaire précoce si pour
l'heure les yvelines ne figure pas parmi
les départements en vigilance
un pic de chaleur pourrait être atteint
ce week-end selon des prévisions météo
france entre 36 et 39 degrés attendus
dans les yvelines ce samedi après midi
n'oubliez pas de bien vous hydrater
merci vous
je faisais et bruce vous restait
quelques mouvements vers nous parce
qu'on va parler de musique ça va parce
que c'est la fête de la musique mardi
luc chatel veut tout dire ce qu'il faut
pas manquer d'ordre dans le départ de
moins bonjour pas très bien pour tout le
monde exactement comme vous l'avez dit
patrice la fed à musique c'est le 21
juin prochain mardi devinez comment deux
villes jouent le jeu des festivités
satander dans le département les
partenaires et seulement 43 plus un
petit indice très bien c'est lié au
département justement c'est exact
je organisent leurs propres fans de la
musique on commence à huy par l'une des
têtes d'affiché du coup la dame blanche
vous donne un rendez vous au parc
charles de gaulle pas en concert gratuit
à 21 heures un concert exotiques sur des
tonalités afro cubaine je vous propose
de découvrir un petit aperçu
[Musique]
maintenant direction guyancourt et la
batterie car ce n'est pas un pas deux
pas trois mais cinq scènes qui seront
mis en place pour toute la soirée à
déployer pour laisser carte blanche à
plein d'artistes ces locations de villas
de découvrir plein de groupes que vous
ne connaissiez pas ou peu je pense à ice
cream réseau funky monkey stec e break
peu importe le style que vous préférez
patrice célia vous trouverez chaussure à
votre pied à la batterie dure en cours
qui vous pourrez penser qu'on n'a pas
les mêmes goûts
c'est pas juste les issues vous vous
écoutez les sonorités ya de tout
franchement il ya vraiment de tout
musique un concert orchestre le rap soul
hip hop célia un petit extrait est ce
que vous voyez un style que vous voulez
écouter du rap le drap enfin on écoute
le groupe calais où
les papilles
la nouvelle donne ces cas les hommes
frangine tu sais que sa voix d'école
c'est kalyan et maintenant parce que
aussi ça fait toujours du bien de
réécouter les grands classiques on part
à versailles avec un concert devant le
château dès 19h30 d atomic frogs un
groupe de reprises de pop rock et soul
que du plaisir j'ai écouté par exemple
reprise de purple rain de prins de 1984
un classique intemporel il accompagne
voilà après pendant tout le concert
d'autres d'autres classiques de la
musique et après si vous voulez cibler
des artistes plus précis à verneuil sur
seine par exemple il y a rocket man
d'elton john qui sera honoré et à bois
d'arcy c'est les tubes du groupe suédois
qu'on ne présente plus a pas et pour
terminer et plus largement mis en
place et des groupes de reprises encore
une fois quand je disais et pour
terminer plus largement je vois là je
voulais vraiment insister sur un point
la beauté de la fête de la musique
finalement c'est vraiment le temps d'un
soir de mettre des artistes locaux des
jeunes des passionnés sous le feu des
projecteurs finalement de les considérer
presque comme des stars mondiales on
vous demande pas de jouer les fanatiques
de remonter sur la scène de crier de
hurler non plus de demander des
autographes sur toutes les parties de
leur corps mais jouer le jeu de
l'événement 78 communes participantes ça
laisse l'embarras du choix d'autant plus
que certains pour sainté pour certaines
polices et des vraies traditions ou pour
ça versailles à rambouillet où les les
rues du centre sont toujours inondés de
monde mais aussi d'autres qui font leurs
premiers pas à trappes par exemple c'est
la première édition cette année
jamais fait un koala seront pour la
première fois donc une chose à dire
soyez au rendez-vous
quand il a lancé la fête de la musique
il a dit je voudrais que chaque français
sortent dans la rue avec son instrument
dans la brume en démocratie a renvoyé ce
qui est théorique on voit pas mal
comment sont les rues quand on voit dans
les ruines en montre au petit jour merci
fabrice devaux il restait sur le plateau
mais je me permet de compléter votre
montigny-le-bretonneux devant le forum
des arts charles aznavour qui a été
récemment inauguré nous avons tram des
balkans qui vient
voilà tram des balkans avec une superbe
soirée et des groupes de studio du forum
des arts qui joueront en première partie
voilà j'en profite
sur le site de la chaîne on va mettre
comme ça beaucoup d'infos sur ce nouveau
forum comme vous disiez et de se
retrouver autour de ce beau ce beau
bâtiment et ben merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup à vous deux et merci beaucoup
vincente
alors maintenant si vous nous rejoignez
en maintenant bas bienvenue à vous on a
parlé donc les torts parce que vous avez
manqué bas mais ça sera rediffusé c'est
ça on a parlé de culture on a parlé
environnement et on va entamer
maintenant une page sports donc on
annoncera aussi une nouvelle émission
sur tv 78 et aussi on parlera un peu
nous continuerons par est une découverte
ou une redécouverte dans l'état des
impôts culture et les arts de saint
quentin en yvelines et donc on va on va
débuter un du coup cette fin d'émission
avec vous mais qu'à la mi-temps avec
mika
reste
j'ai mis du temps à choisir
et vous avez beaucoup d'avis trois
invités oui mais 2,5 différents deux
sports différents va commencer peut être
par le vtt c'est dans l'émission
alors on va parler de la revanche at qui
s'est déroulé le week-end dernier sur la
colline d'elancourt un site de 2 131
mètres d'altitude et qui a été choisi
pour être le site futur site des du vtt
pendant les jeux anglio 2024 les jo de
2024 et avec vous du coup thierry fabre
vous êtes l'organisateur vous êtes
également président du vc de sky team
vous sert alors est-ce que ça s'est bien
passé tout simplement oui très bien la
dernière édition avant le début des
travaux 180 partant bonne ambiance dont
dans l'amitié dans l'esprit sportif de
la combativité d'entre elles et puis
surtout comme c'est une course au profit
des orphelins des sapeurs pompiers de
france n'a pu renverser 1000 euros à nos
enfants parce que moi je suis sapeur
pompier professionnel dans le
département donc voilà mais ça fait 28
ans et ça que la course a été créé
pourquoi cet appel à royan shard part de
la revancha parce que c'était la colline
d'alors rome 2 la revanche avec en fait
d'augmenter à chaque fois dessus pas
montées mythiques c'était une
revancharde qui était un symbole trouve
un nom par rapport à la commune de la
revanche qui maintenant ils acolytes
d'elancourt d'accord on disait que les 2
la revanche c'est de savoir ça et puis
notre fierté que nous ayons c'est qu'on
a fait du vtt depuis 1998 la première
édition et puis beaucoup de courses 28
revancharde championnats d'europe deux
championnats d'europe des uniformes
championnat national fsgt on a fait dans
le mode course et puis cette petite idée
de course et de d'engouement je pense a
fait connaître le site pour les jeux
sans l'appliquer est ce qu'on peut dire
que c'est maintenant rendez vous
incontournable 7,7 revancharde un loyer
elle attendue on n'a fait aucune pub 11
jan aps aucune pub 185 m vous même vous
êtes en tunisie où vous l'avez fait pas
non je dirige parce qu'on peut pas être
celle d'or pour pas tenir la baguette et
puis
j'avais dit rien sur le jour de
réalisation je peux vous dire il est
unique en bas je sais même pas comment
j'ai fait des fois je sors ou 2,8 après
robin s'est plus fait en somme c'est
peut-être avez-vous quoi
alors cette compétition vous l'avez dit
c'est la dernière avant les jeux
olympiques de 2024 mais la dernière sur
le site on est d'accord hier sur le site
on s'oriente perdre mais on est là
revancharde je suis en train de
travailler sur un projet en forêt de
rambouillet sur sa religion en ligne
ouais sur saint léger voilà donc un beau
parcours bonjour oui il faut perdurer
cette cause trop tôt ce qui pour se
rallier à votre bon 23 en début de
saison pas s'arrêter il faut un outil
nuit de seconds rôles en charme
continuer notre histoire et surtout
continuer à aider les orphelins des
sapeurs présidence et et après les jo
vous reviendrez locaux
voilà c'est de la terre
sera un site tfc ne dit pas ce qui est
des travaux mais on peut pas on pourra
pas y retourner avant après 2025 parce
qu'après les jeux il ya l'héritage des
constructions pour l'héritage on pourra
pas faire nos courses on ne se
connaissait pas l'héritage suite des
essais des travaux sur la colline pour
prendre la colline des travaux
pour le bénéfice oui tout à fait et vous
avez également travaillé sur le dossier
du vtt sur cette colline de la revanche
a aidé en cours il ya quelques quelques
temps nous a demandé de
proposer nos circuits à saint quentin en
yvelines et saint-quentin-en-yvelines
donc à travailler également avec une
partie du seuil haut et on s'aperçoit
qu'aujourd'hui le parcours pédestre avec
le panneautage qu'il ya sur la colline
c'est à 70% le circuit de la revancharde
pour nous c'est un honneur
c'est un honneur et on peut le dire vous
êtes expert des dieux on peut on peut le
dire il n'y a pas mieux vous sur cette
colline de la revanche ouais tout eu en
toute humilité et aknoul s'occuperont du
site on a on dépollue en dépolluant on
façonne deux circuits mais faut dire que
saint quentin en yvelines ou si nous
aide énormément et la ville des noms
courts parce qu'il met à notre
disposition des moyens de forestage des
tracteurs etc
et puis si tu es intéressé télé c'était
très dur parce qu'il n'a pas fait la
revanche en depuis deux ans et la
végétation et normand au pouce et il a
fallu
pour mes bénévoles on a passé 12 12
journées complètes pour rendre le
circuit viable puisque parmi les
sportifs que vous pressez attaqué six
autres où soient dans votre vélo club
qui aura beaucoup de bénévoles pour les
provinciaux oui j'en ai j'en ai
quelques-uns qui ont postulé d'ailleurs
pour la revanche avait quinze bénévoles
de saint quentin en yvelines qui ont
postulé pour être
bénévole jo j'ai noté avec une
appréciation sur sur trois critères
et puis comme ça ils auront une chance
d'être choisis oui j'étais un petit peu
aidé quand même j'ai dit
apte à puteaux compétition vtt et merci
pour ce soutien les orphelins j'espère
que ce petit plus
c'est une très belle oeuvre l'oeuvre des
orphelins de défauts pierre
housieaux le site fait 231 m dos je le
disais précédemment est-ce qui sera à la
hauteur de l'événement planétaire à
votre avis ben oui un incontestablement
oui oui je sais mais c'est sûr que le
les vacances sont un petit peu de mal à
l'imaginer mais ça va être prêt tout
sera prêt dans deux ans tout sera prêt
faut pas s'inquiéter ça va être un super
parcours moi j'ai déjà vu les vues sur
les parcours mais si c'est un petit peu
si je vous dis le mot extraordinaire ça
vous suffira à rythme était bon
et vous connaissez ce qui était dans les
airs avec nous les compétiteurs et on
connaît la qualité du circuit qu à voir
en connaît deux lieux et surtout
l'engouement autour des jeux olympiques
j'ai ri c'est comme j'explique souvent à
mes partenaires aux bénévoles locaux
jeune de chez moi et même manu pistard
j'ai les jeux olympiques en france ça
sera peut-être une fois tous les cent
ans et à 50 ans un petit plus jamais oui
je suis au point un habillage couvrir
l'événement c'est ce que je dis à mes
pistard qui ont des chances d'aller aux
jeux olympiques parce que est-ce qu'on a
des chances justement de bétail en vtt
ou rio
oui oui oui oui maintenant si je fais un
beau danube où ça s'est un peu compliqué
le sport comme donné pourquoi c'est
l'incertitude une science exacte et la
certitude
il ya tous les blogueuses à certains du
sport comme on dit parce qu'on peut dire
que nous avons chez skyteam bruce r on
défaisant répliquons les voir de près
les mêmes les championnats du monde sur
piste parce que j'ai des pistards de
l'équipe de france j'ai déjà médaille
olympique en équipe de france de vitesse
florian brembo claraco phonique a de
grandes chances d'aller aux jeux quant à
l'as far ou s'il ya des chances qu'ils
me gillot est en paralympiques on a
quand un camion qui va faire les jeux
olympiques avec un non-voyant avec
raphaël et on a notre petit petite gêne
dignement gènes de pêcheurs qui se
lancent dans l'aventuré jop il faut
qu'elle soit sélectionné mais a déjà eu
un bon résultat et vient de finir
troisièmes au championnat de france du
chrono et en ligne en vélo couché en
handisport un survient voilà c'est on va
suivre ça toute façon évidemment merci
beaucoup
merci pour le rendez vous de l'année
prochaine pour la revancharde oui mais
pas de souci fut
gardé secret
continue
c'est ça le rugby avec deux
personnalités du club de versailles qui
nous ont rejoints sur ce plat soyez
polis parce que je me couche pas
alors vous êtes vous allez monter du
coup l'année prochaine en fédérale 2
racontez nous tiphaine le
manager moi je suis le manager et
entraîneur de l'équipe première du rcv
et du coup firme acquis et les mains et
capitaine de l'équipe exactement
exactement notre fer de lance voilà bien
le week-end
avait mis d'accord donc et les raisons
de faire gaffe
alors vous êtes qualifiés c'est ça pour
la fédérale 2 c'est une grande première
pour l'histoire du rcv du rc versailles
vous avez battu 31 à 21 à vincennes
dimanche dernier après avoir perdu le
match aller mais à la différence de
points vous êtes devant vous allez donc
passé en fédérale 2 victoires qu'est ce
que ça vous fait tout simplement écouter
mois
j'avais à coeur de de poursuivre
justement tout ce qui a été fait dans
les années antérieures puisque c'est un
club quand même une centenaire et
aujourd'hui voilà on a réussi quelque
chose d'extraordinaire puisque le club
n'est jamais montée en fédérale 2 donc
si vous voulez c'est une immense
satisfaction c'est jeu s'est passé plein
de bonheur c'est plein de choses c'est
tout le club qui c'est qui s'est levé
les petits collectifs actuellement c'est
le collectif c'est ça c'est un travail
vraiment de de plusieurs années ça fait
ça fait quatre cinq ans que la nouvelle
direction essaye d'impulser quelque
chose de fort et au travers de nouba on
essaie de réaliser des objectifs donc
forcément on est tous allés tous très
contents et puis on est tous heureux de
ces résultats mais
il ya du
week-end mais vers c'est que ça devienne
ville de sport un voyage et le football
qui est martin nationale
écoutez nous l'objectif il est aussi
clair c'est que on veut s'installer
comme le plus gros clubs du département
en terme de rugby donc pour l'instant
plaisir était devant c'est un petit peu
leur rivalité intense plaisir était en
fédérale 2 vous vous étiez en fédérale 3
donc la volonté en fédérale 2
matchs si je peux dire oui mais il ya
quatre ans et nous les voilà le club
progresse en progression constante de
tous ses cadres quatre années puisqu'il
y avait quand même deux divisions
d'écart est donc aujourd'hui voilà
l'ambition clair c'est de devenir le
voilà le club phare du jdd plateau du
département 218 et aujourd'hui voilà on
a un on a une direction qui met les
moyens en oeuvre pour pouvoir justement
lettres et et le but exactement ces deux
de faire venir justement des gens de
l'extérieur et que et que les gens aient
envie et plaisir de venir nous rejoindre
dans cette aventure ça veut dire d'autre
c'est à dire tous bénévoles on en
parlait tout à l'heure volaille comme
avec le vélo ça veut dire des joueurs ça
veut dire des enfants ça veut dire des
jeunes oui c'est du 18 continuer à
travailler voilà sur sur la performance
sur sur les bons résultats et c'est vrai
que cette année c'est une année
particulière parce qu'on a eu plein de
gros résultats sur toutes les catégories
voilà que ce soit sur le dr les u16 et
u18 voilà et
il ya de la relève est exactement donc
ça c'est vraiment une grosse
satisfaction pour vous donner un petit
peu les les mots clés l'école de rugby a
été championne du tournoi de trignac les
les 8-16 sont restés sont maintenus dans
la division nationale qu'il a plu aux
divisions amateurs puisque les autres
divisions sont accessibles que pour les
propres les clubs professionnels on a
noué 18 qui ont fait quart de finale et
contre perdu d'un seul poids dans une
fin de match un peu cauchemardesque
contre le club de nîmes ils perdent d'un
point et ils finissent champions donc on
pouvait penser un petit peu dans nos
rêves que est la finalité nos juniors
pourrait venir voilà les finir champion
et puis on a notre équipe iii seniors
qui est champion d'île de france voilà
nos seniors 2 qui ont été qualifiés 1er
poule est qualifié pour laisser tout
coeur
c'est la fête pour tout le monde voilà
et c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il ya
une grosse communion une grosse réunion
pour les matchs les matchs apport
fontaine et oui parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de monde autour du terrain à chaque fois
par chantal et notamment sur ses matches
à enjeu ces derniers matchs de la saison
où vous étiez dans cette course à la
fédération on peut on peut dire qu'il
n'y avait pas qu'un bull pas qu'un
seizième homme ou un 23e - 25e on avait
je crois que il y avait toute une vie
vraiment moi j'apprends laventure le
projet il ya un an et demi l'année
dernière s'était coupé par le cos vide
mais des live barça était la fédérale 2
l'objectif lors d'ailleurs on a proposé
à fédéral de mon habillement pouvoir
monter sur le terrain et simplement
aurait pas parce que les mouvements
qu'on avait plus de nerfs semaine c'est
extra rien leur communion que hillary
clinton qui avait plus en parler l'école
de rugby et c'est vrai que lucas n'a
prévu qu'un de tous et il a dans les
voit sauter sur le côté donc super vous
avez été surpris par l'ambiance soit ou
pas au rcv là encore c'est au tour du
terrain trouver comment il sait surtout
que c'est le club de ville est souvent
en rugby c'est souvent le club de
village qui vous allez mener dans les
grandes villes on retrouve pas forcément
très sain et du coup j'ai vraiment été
surpris agréablement surpris bien sûr
avec des fumigènes et des dirigeants les
ultras versailles et un patrice et je
traversais qui sont tous y en vraiment
effet c'est bien
c'est dimanche ont fait 10 l'image on
encore ko des 80 minutes et égale les
fumigènes roses cirta platanes et des
gens qui demain dans les selles fille
les enfants qui courent partout à battre
la droite vous sollicitez et puis le
public est vraiment important c'est ce
qui vaut aussi
saisie
c'est que dans le sport un peu aussi il
a dû du combat etc où c'est un peu dur
où il ya l'affrontement comme ça c'est
vrai que le soutien du public il est il
est hyper important et c'est vrai qu'on
avait déjà eu un petit prémices quand on
est monté de donneurs à fédérale 3 on
avait déjà senti qu'il y avait un
collectif il traversa effet derrière et
pousser ses poussées on avait déjà fait
un petit un petit reportage dessus et ça
pousse très très bien et voilà et il
faut bien sûr il faut les suivre parce
que je pense que ils n'ont pas fini et
ils vont encore nous suivre l'année
prochaine toute la saison et on va
essayer de faire encore mieux et bien
sûr comment vous l'avez fêter ce titre
du coup avec les supporteurs mais entre
vous l'avez fait et comment on va dire
[Musique]
[Rires]
que ça et c'est quoi la suite du coup la
fédérale 2 est ce que vous voulez vous
maintenir en fédérale 2 l'année
prochaine est ce que vous pouvez encore
monter
quels sont les objectifs de l'objectif
il comme je vous l'aï dit tout à l'heure
c'est d'être
phare du 78 donc forcément finir devant
plaisir on va essayer en tout cas de
bien figurer le but c'est de monter avec
des ambitions voilà on a une comme je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure la direction
souhaite pas monter pour monter mais en
tout cas bien s'y installer
des trois c'est pas les pros vite donc
c'est à dire qu'on va pas faire les
premiers plans en tout cas on veut jouer
le milieu de tableau avec de l'ambition
exactement et après voir s'il ya plus
donc ça veut dire forcément étoffer le
staff étoffé au niveau des joueurs et
les forcément mettre les moyens pour
pouvoir recruter à tout à fait firmin
vous êtes heureux dans de cette montée
de jouer des prochaines enfin pleinement
est-ce que vous allez rester à
versailles ouf tout on attend cette
réponse est oui on attend un département
la réponse est oui je vais refaire un
entretien vidéo encore avec ferment
et vous avez visé continue à miser sur
le côté familial j'imagine ce côté
joueurs du cru ou pas pour gêner le jeu
je pense sincèrement que il ya encore la
place en fédérale 2 pour pouvoir avoir
le double parcours c'est à dire un
parcours un petit peu
au queen bee stick mais avec de belles
ambitions avec des vraies exigences et
aussi avoir l'esprit famille l'esprit
convivialité et nous c'est quelque chose
au rcv qu'on veut qu'on veut maintenir
parce que c'est notre adn pour notre
réel voilà c'est les valeurs qu'on
dégage donc ça il n'y a pas de
discussion là dessus et est clairement
on fera tout pour justement jumeler les
deux dans vos dit merde
merci beaucoup merci merci
merci tirer alors on va rester dans ce
cas on va continuer la page fort puisque
le collège on aurait pu s que le collège
giacometti de montigny le bretonneux va
ouvrir à la rentrée à 2022 une nouvelle
section sportive alors quel sport à
votre avis je le sais donc chers
cricket n'ont
jamais
personne de joe greene a fait c'est ça
qui est belle à thoiry patrice si vous
êtes très raide il faut être anglais
n'ont pas forcément une équipe de
cricket a fait six mois qu'ils sont
jumelés avec rossi également dans le
viseur parce qu'on n'est pas loin de
cricket pc la version numérique elles
sont exactes et donc ce sera du baseball
désolé messieurs donc à raison de quatre
heures par semaine avec un emploi du
temps aménagé regardez ce reportage
doté d'un casque d'un gant et d'une
batte ils sont 14 à s'entraîner à cette
nouvelle discipline sportive de baseball
moi j'avais déjà commencé à mettre en
place aura du baseball mois l'activité
me plaît beaucoup et les et la joie est
que massa il a attiré pas mal donc moi
je trouvais que c'était plutôt
intéressant qui ont alors bénéficié la
l'installation de très bonne qualité qui
fait partie des meilleurs stades de
france de baseball le collège va ouvrir
à la rentrée 2022 une nouvelle section
sportive les collégiens auront ainsi
quatre heures de baseball par semaine en
plus de la hesse le mercredi après midi
leur emploi du temps sera alors aménagé
pour qu'ils puissent suivre les
entraînements et pour conclure cette
année ils affrontaient les cougars de
montigny
[Musique]
c'était mon père qui faisait des baies
du baseball et avant je faisais du foot
donc il m'a dit si tu veux tu peux faire
du baseball pour essayer si tu aimes
bien je continue mais vu que j'adore
maintenant je continue on va dire c'est
un sport qui change c'est hors du commun
il ya beaucoup de beaucoup de règles il
ya beaucoup de choses à réfléchir c'est
un sport autant individuel que collectif
donc je pense qu'il se sent qu'il ya sur
les jeux cette nouvelle section sportive
est ouverte aux enfants allant de la 6e
à la 3e tous niveaux confondus
alors sur tv 78 on essaye de diversifier
notre offre deux programmes un bon
lancer de nouvelles démissions est-ce
que vous parler un petit peu anglais fut
un clic
et bientôt mise à jour 18 pas trop tôt
dit une nouvelle émission one two three
désolé pour mon anglais ainsi
on peut peut-être déjà regarder un
extrait se ressemblent
alors c'est qu'ils parlent très frileuse
lycée alexandrine payé puisque c'est
vous qui présentait cette émission par
l'exode bilingue faut dire ça alors qu
est raccordé doux c'est quoi cette
émission one two three one two three
c'est un talk show 100% en anglais qui
permet en fait aux américains ou anglais
ou même n'importe quelle personne qui
parle couramment anglais dans les
yvelines à faire une expérience sur son
un plateau à monter sur un plateau est
en fait exprimé ou partager leurs
opinions sur certains sujets alors non
seulement politiques mais culturelles
sociales contemporaines et et en fait ça
lui permet de pouvoir parler dans une
langue qui sont confortables dans leur
propre au volant et là vous aviez trois
invités rock et qui était ou pour nous
le cicuit à peu près oui bien sûr alors
il y avait en fait j'essaie de trouver
des personnes avec un profil différent
mais aussi avec des points communs j'ai
par exemple là on avait trois
nationalités mais ils ont tous vécu en
amérique un moment il y avait john start
c'est un écrivain américain
tony de souza qui est free lance qui
anglais et paula qui fait des guides
touristiques pour les expats dans les
yvelines qui est portugaise dacor ac et
portugaise de l'accord et c'est l
écrivain qui disait qu'on est un pays
très très porté sur la mode c'est ça ils
vont
c'est alors c'est passionnant parce que
c'est vrai que si si vous êtes anglais
pour la démission mais si vous voulez
progresser un petit peu blessé par balle
aussi d'essayer de comprendre c'est vrai
c'est bien peut-être que on essayait de
la sous titré un jour je sais pas ce
serait parce que j'ai regardé et là il y
avait des thèmes dans cette émission oui
bien sûr pas du coup on a pu aborder sur
beaucoup plus de sujets grâce à des
profils très différents donc on a fait
la france la politique française en
comparaison à la poétique américaines et
anglaises les mentalités différentes des
trois pays notamment on a un peu parlé
aussi du coc vide où on est maintenant
comment il se sent à par rapport à ça et
à la fin c'est bien de laisser un peu un
sujet léger donc c'est bientôt la fête
de la musique et ont du coup on a
discuté des jazz parce que ils sont
passionnés de ça et
bravo tout cas parce que parce que
d'abord et c'est vrai que
présence des missions spécifiques à
la
rédaction qui pourraient présenter
l'émission en belge
c'est la trique jeu
alors patrick vous allez
vous allez nous parler d'une institution
patrick
contournant si vous êtes saint
quentinois vous pouvez pas passer de
passer pardon à côté du bistrot du
théâtre on appelle aussi bdt jeu bdt
exactement michael donc c'est vraiment
un peu trop cet établissement s'est
passé le bureau du travail notre réseau
patrice à jour c'est à vous qu'il est
urgent et au bdt de l'obésité il va
bosser
chez lanvin musique est juste en face du
théâtre voilà donc c'est dans cette
brasserie au décor au traditionnel avec
sa carte à tendance bistrotière
classique que les patrons de gilles et
franck c'est indissociable binôme on
peut le dire les tic et tac de la place
pour des jeux il ya un bar use il ya un
barbu avec une chemise noire normalement
et je sais pas si on veut le voir sur
les images on déclare comme ça il est
toujours à qu'une chemise noire et les
bretelles rouges
je vise le top 10 sont la matrice voilà
c'est de lui alors lui c'est gilles c
est donc frank sont associés et donc ils
peuvent vous accueillir
en salle ou en terrasse
en ce moment il fait très chaud alors où
seulement michael célia patrice guex
dorsale est ce que vous avez le torse à
une idée de la capacité d'accueil en
salle par exemple
45e allez tu veux dire 60
c'est un peu plus un petit peu plus
c'est ce que 78e
on en rajoute
on va dire voilà elle est très grande
mrl bon parfois il peut si jamais
vraiment aller blindés il peut il peut
encore en maître des places mais en
moyenne combien de passes michael
je ne sais pas parce que des fois j'ai
connu j'ai connu des soirées de coupe du
monde où il devait avoir moins 200
personnes mais je sais pas si je suis
dans le haut de la terrasse quand je dis
la terrasse porter énormément de monde
là c'est 110 places ainsi si je vois
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal
alors nos deux amis combien de céleri
ont-ils iso ils sont deux c pour ça
qu'on attend
le serveur les jolies la ville un
message du zen un peu plus vingtaine
dont 15 15 15 elle est alors hommes à
tenir question c'est quelle est la
moyenne du nombre de repas servis tous
les midis faut savoir que c'est un vin à
partir des années 80 et 110 à son
enfant est en fait en moyenne 850 à
lewes et 535
me dit ça tours et ça attire énormément
d'entreprises aux alentours il ya
beaucoup d'habitués là bas tu viens je
fais pas partie
n'était pas du côté bar
vous y trouverez un fameux panel de
bière au fus que le patron s'amuse à
changer régulièrement pour nous faire
partager et découvrir sa passion de ces
breuvages houblonnée s'il vous plaît
vous y dégusterez entre autres un
produit 100% local puisque l'une d'elles
le quelques-unes de ces bib mousse comme
on dit chez nous ajouterons des débits
nous viennent en direct de la brasserie
o'clock de bois d'arcy donc c'est juste
à côté ah oui assez bien celles
auxquelles beaucoup cette brasserie les
je crois qu'il essaye même de faire une
bière au nom du vdt mail au club je
crois qu'ils essayent de 50 ans
était en train de boire un cocktail
tout à fait patrice
coquelle très surprenant a effectivement
fait ce cocktail s'appelle le zizi coin
coin un bon il faut le trouver règle
sans alcool que c'est un cocktail que
j'avais goûté en belgique ce qui est
très très local donc j'étais très très
étonné de trouver ce cocktail chimique
belge et ses danseuses en wallonie ah
oui exactement à côté de liège mais
c'est vraiment même en belgique tout le
monde connaît pas le physique en coin et
j'ai trouvé sont ici coincoin la haye
lors du zizi coin coin pour c'est pas
très malin comme non j'ai fait des
recherches alors que celui-ci pointe -
vous savez vous pourquoi céder zico
points et maintenant vous allez me dire
patrick a
absolument aucun rapport avec les
américains vous a donc ça s'appelle le
sait faire de mal pour le zeste de
citron d'où le zizi zeste de citron
d hydro voilà et le coin coin il vient
de la liqueur d'orange de boîtes ont
rejoint trop
[Musique]
je suis très
gêné la chanson à busan week-end
précédent à buzet en tous les cas c'est
que je suis le gars avec des glaçons ce
très rapidement fait pas de boire quand
même en cas faisait absolument
restaurant que qui est très bien noté
elles sont établies cet établissement
est justement classé pour son excellent
rapport qualité prix on y trouve une
bonne cuisine de brasserie c'est de la
brasserie on est dedans avec une carte
assez diversifiée et son traditionnel
plat du jour qui suit la saisonnalité
des fruits et des légumes
tranquille
voilà à noter que les tartes action
couper au couteau s'il vous plaît ce
n'est pas toujours le cas souvent on
trouve les tartares h et en fait et là
ils sont coupés au couteau et on y
trouve même un tartare times michael
hart lane par ta taille j'ajoute et leur
jeter des oeufs
non je n'ai jamais goûté que certains
tags j'espère seuil est atteint la
côte et restent secrètes il n'a pas
voulu me donner la recette mais voilà
ça c'est à tartas sous la forme semble
en réserve mais voilà il ya des petites
choses voilà pour conclut ben tout
simplement donc on peut dire que c'est
une ambiance sympa et détendue mon petit
trouver des soirées à thème des soirées
concerts et même des soirées avec des
diffusions d'événements sportifs mettez
de la commune
c'est vrai
[Musique]
il a été ouvert si tout à fait en
1988 si j'ai bon souvenir de la venue
sur youtube donc je sais que j'ai donné
des années qu'elles sont mais non non
non
l'alcool est dangereux
et juste et alors que s'est ouvert du
lundi au samedi fermé le dimanche et si
vraiment vraiment vous voulez pas vous
déplacer je vous invite à aller voir
leur compte facebook instagram qui sont
plutôt sympas il est petit à petit point
rajoelina
voila voila c'est sympa c'est le fait
que l'animateur de vote
attention
merci d'être ici c'est bien les gars
merci beaucoup avec solena sa merci
beaucoup c'est dieu merci patrice et on
se retrouve bientôt bien savouré huit
nouvelles formules et à merci
[Musique]